um any features on the new album uh yeah
uh
who you don't know uh
got a song with cool keith oh shout out
to cool kids yeah shout out to you
[Music]
whenever you come back to planet earth
we issued the video for it cool keys
that guy
yeah cool keeps a guy but he i don't
know where he's at right now he's in
mars yeah
he's cool keeps getting cool keys yeah i
got a
uh nibs [ __ ] your life gorilla gorilla
names was just here last week yeah
conan he's from coney island you guys
like coney island he's been in detroit a
lot of times he know why laconia he
almost signed with eminem he had like an
opportunity where he could have got on
shady but you know he had some [ __ ]
happen in his life yeah he went to uh
prison for a minute yeah yeah
so after my boy names man i've been
knowing i do for a long time what i love
is his he also has very
disrespectful
flagrant bars
he gotta be saying he's doing that for a
long crazy [ __ ] on your album oh yeah
he's saying someone else he probably saw
he was like bizarre this feature i'm
gonna say the wildest [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah he said the kobe line though it
might be unacceptable what do you say oh
man
he said uh what'd he say
he said something about [ __ ] you can
get this
game i gave my mama gave my mom and my
sister some cover for christmas
that's fine some [ __ ] he said
yeah
then i got young z on the album oh young
z from the outside
that's old school
yeah
yeah
i got uh they're from uh jersey right
yeah yeah yep yep i remember that yeah
yeah uh
guilty simpson from detroit [ __ ] man i
had guilty simpson on my show in 2010
man i haven't heard that name in a long
time yeah yeah that's a detroit you know
it's crazy because detroit there's so
many like uh
genres of detroit hip-hop so like when i
was growing up obviously eminem
d12 was like oh we choice obi tries but
then there was
slum village there was j dilla there was
black milk there was guilty simpson
there was all those guys obviously royce
it was and then now like detroit's like
low-key like
top two or three hottest city in all of
rap music everyone's getting signed out
of detroit yeah the street [ __ ] coming
out of detroit is crazy
yeah doug
who's going to detroit right now i [ __ ]
with baby money who just came up here he
just said yeah that's my boy from 12th
street yeah vezo is probably my favorite
uh i love um
i think babytron's got really funny like
one lines yeah his dad was signed to
psychopath records yeah which is funny a
lot of people don't know that yeah uh
you you in tune
yeah uh
yeah i mean 42 doug those i would say
he's so big that like yeah yeah you got
to get him out of the underground yeah
but he's [ __ ] hard bro yeah for sure
his voice is insane right his tone is
crazy yeah we grow with his daddy's dad
was a cheddar boy he saw a cheddar boy
shout out to the eastside cheddar boys
yeah
shout out to shout out to cute man i
just checked out because i had met
little blade uh blade icewood son out
there okay and uh i just checked i
actually just got around to finally
listening to this [ __ ] his [ __ ] is cool
shot low blade obviously payroll
giovanni is going crazy but he's been
going crazy for [ __ ] years um yeah no
detroit is detroit's going up right now
man yeah like qc just signed vezzo and
they had signed baby money so qc is
tapping in heavy yeah yeah
i'm proud man we're going crazy man